we have some good news this morning for
weary commuters around Philadelphia take
a look at this time lapse video it shows
road crews working around the clock to
rebuild a critical section of I-95 that
collapsed a week and a half ago and now
according to Pennsylvania's Governor
this section of that major highway will
at least partially reopen this weekend
that is much sooner than expected Elaine
Keanu has more now on this massive and
massively Innovative effort to get
traffic moving again
when this bridge collapsed on Interstate
95 after a fatal tanker truck explosion
10 days ago oh boy it cut off more than
000 daily commuters from a crucial
stretch of highway for the entire
Northeast there's a lot of inconvenience
and detours and everybody's having a
hard time but after days of demolition
clearing debris and construction
Pennsylvania's Governor says this
portion of I-95 will partially reopen
this weekend our commuters will finally
be able to set their Monday morning
alarm clocks back to the regular time
our struggling local businesses here
will hopefully be filled again to fill
the Gap created by the collapsed
overpass in order to build new Lanes on
top Engineers used something called
recycled glass aggregate rock-like
material made from recycled bottles and
jars officials were quick to defend the
construction safety I have 100
confidence in its ability to withstand
the traffic that's on that facility it's
a very simple design that can be
constructed very quickly and that's why
it's happening so fast professor of
engineering Michael shaja says it's
difficult to prevent catastrophic damage
when accidents like this happen it's
hard to fire proof of Ridge there's no
prohibition against
um the types of vehicles that go over it
but there's no ban on on vehicles that
might be very combustible for CBS
mornings I'm Elaine quijano